magician and overall nobody asked you to
do that stunt artist david blaine
recently made headlines when he used
balloons to lift himself nearly
five miles above the arizona desert
before skydiving back down earth sure
that's a daring and
cool stunt i suppose but people
comparing it to the movie up are getting
a little
carried away if you ask me i mean if he
really wanted to do the up
trick properly he would have landed from
that skydive and
then revealed that he had a boy scout
with him the entire time
now that is a trick
[Music]
hello internet welcome to film theory
the show that helps your knowledge of
movies and tv sort of new heights before
bursting your balloons by ruining your
favorite franchises
i can't help it i'm like life's pointy
little needle of sadness
let's ignore that ominous foreshadowing
for a moment though and consider the
majesty of
pixar with almost no new movies coming
out in 2020 i've had a fantastic
opportunity to revisit some old classics
no not the bygone classics from the
golden age of film or under-appreciated
futuristic anime or even obscure french
documentaries about potato picking ah
leglen
you will always remain in my watch later
playlist
nope i've been watching old pixar movies
haven't exactly kept my love of pixar
secret on this channel but sometimes it
can be tricky to talk about their movies
i've actually wanted to make a theory
about up for a long time but every time
i start to watch the movie i get so
dehydrated from
weeping after that first 10 minutes that
i have to stop if you've never made it
past those first 10 minutes either let
me spoiler alert summarize the movie so
we can get on with today's theory shall
we and up an old man named carl uses
balloons to fly his and his late wife's
house to their dream adventure
destination of paradise falls in south
america along with an annoying boy scout
and a talking dog wow it is a remarkably
easy movie to summarize now the obvious
theory about up is about whether you can
actually make a house
fly with balloons and while a number of
videos have attempted to answer this
even going so far as to build a
miniature of carl's house and fly it
i've never been satisfied with the
answer or the methodology or the math
that's been used and i've also been left
unsatisfied when everyone fails to
answer
the other obvious question here even if
you do manage to get the house in the
air is there any chance that it could
possibly make it to another
continent i guess when you want
something done right you have to do it
yourself and that my friends is the plan
for today's theory
so my friends strap in like david blaine
because today we're going up
up and away the first question that we
have to dig into is the obvious
one whether carl could actually have
floated his house using balloons as we
see in the movie
and i recognize that i am far from the
first person to actually try to answer
this david blaine demonstrated that you
can do it with a person
and the national geographic show how
hard can it be
proved that you could do it with a house
so i gotta say the house that they built
was more of a house-shaped box
than something that people could
actually live in which is gonna come
with a lot of stuff that's gonna weigh
the whole project down
the theoretical physics behind it isn't
all that complicated since helium is
lighter than air a balloon creates a
small lifting force and if you get
enough helium in enough balloons yeah
you could theoretically lift anything
a house a yacht even the statue of
liberty the real question is how many
balloons you'd need and that one
requires a bit more work i've seen
estimates of this figure online ranging
from wired's claim that the job would be
done in about a hundred thousand
balloons to the director of up
pete docter saying that the figure they
arrived at was somewhere in the vicinity
of 23 and a half
million balloons a bit of a difference
there's a
you know margin of error nice try there
guys but here on film theory you only
get partial credit if you don't show
your work so i wanted to do the math for
myself along with a bit of testing from
our pal austin over on the science on
game theory
first question how much does carl's
house weigh there are actually a lot of
considerations depending on the
materials that you use to make the house
but generally speaking
older houses are made from heavier
materials
carl and ellie renovate a house known as
a queen anne
style house which are what you think of
as your classic victorian houses
think high-pitched roofs tower
structures or bay windows and porches
with ornate lattice work called
gingerbread trim
we can also see that carl's house has a
heavy slate roof that's why you're
getting that scalloped pattern up there
on the top of the building
this house was probably built in the
early 20th century at the latest given
that it was falling apart when carl and
ellie made in it in 1939. according to
one construction company a good estimate
for the weight of a two-story house like
carl's is 275 pounds per square foot
though we have to subtract the weight of
the house's foundation from that because
when house lifts up you don't see the
foundation coming with it
luckily the up house now exists a
replica was actually built in the
suburbs of salt lake city utah and
covers 2
800 square feet so even if we imagine it
having a heavy foundation of 200 000
pounds or 91 000 kilograms we've still
got ourselves a weight of
570 000
260 000 kilograms that we need to lift
using nothing but
balloons so as you can imagine we're
gonna need a lot of balloons
so that leads us to our second question
how much weight can a helium balloon
lift
obviously this question depends on the
kind of balloon both mr street magic and
the people of national geographic
opted for big meteorological balloons
but if we want to recreate up we're
talking about latex party city rub it on
your head and stick it to the wall kind
of balloons
on average one of these balloons can fit
about 9 liters of helium in it which
should have the ability to lift about 11
grams of mass
we also have to start subtracting the
weight of the non-house things that the
helium is also lifting the balloon
itself weighs about 2 grams and if we
imagine carl using very
thin fishing line for the strings which
i chose because the ribbon that you get
on party balloons would actually be too
heavy at the lengths that carl needs
that's going to add about another 0.7
grams for a 50 foot length
string thus each balloon has the ability
to lift about 8.3 grams if we're not
accounting for any other outward forces
like the friction of the balloons
rubbing together
converting the total weight of the house
from 570
000 pounds to about 258 million 547
thousand 651 grams
we get that carl is gonna need a grand
total
of 31 million 150
319 balloons to get that house
off the ground having trouble
envisioning what that number of balloons
would look like well here's some footage
from balloon fest which happened in
cleveland ohio just a couple of miles
from where i was born
two months from before i was born in
september of 1986
in an attempt to break the guinness
world record for the most balloons
released
at one time what you're seeing in that
news coverage right there is
one and a half million helium balloons
so carl's house would need that times 20
probably
blocking out the sun in the process also
did cleveland's balloon fest have as
nice of an ending as up nope guinness
refused to recognize it as a world
record and the balloons hampered a
search and rescue mission for two lost
fishermen who wound up dead
classic cleveland pulling a cleveland
it's not funny that people died at all
it's just such a cleveland move i love
you guys we originated the rock and roll
hall of fame
and the ability to set rivers on fire
because they're so polluted i'm
originally from cleveland so i'm allowed
to make that joke but cleveland is like
the double baltic of cities i love you
cleveland
so much okay so theoretically you can
lift your house into the sky if you have
30 million spare balloons lying around
but that still doesn't confirm the
events of the film because we have to
answer our other major question here
could carl really fly the house to
paradise falls
unfortunately when you have 30 million
balloons attached to your house shower
curtain isn't gonna be super effective
at steering it
like trying to steer your car by
sticking your arm out the window so
carl is gonna be at the mercy of wind
patterns but there is
some indication that the wind might
actually end up blowing carl's house
toward paradise falls paradise falls as
location doesn't really exist in real
life but it's based on venezuela's angel
falls the tallest waterfall in the world
it's unclear where in the united states
carl is from but from anywhere in the
lower 48 he's gonna be needing to be
blown
south and east landing somewhere near
the equator the eastern direction for
weather is pretty typical
north of 30 degrees latitude which is
pretty much all of america the
predominant wind pattern is the
subtropical
jet stream which blows from west to east
opposite the direction that the earth is
spinning in order to go
south the house needs to get caught up
in what's called a hadley cell which is
a rotating mass of air that occurs
between the equator and about 30 degrees
latitude air from the equator heats up
rises high in the atmosphere and moves
towards the poles at which point the air
cools down
sinks and moves back toward the equator
it's certainly lucky
for carl's house to end up around
paradise falls but when you look at the
weather patterns
it's not impossible and if you think
it's impossible for helium balloons to
travel that kind of distance there's
actually anecdotal evidence to suggest
otherwise
in 2013 a british student released
helium balloons with
letters attached to him into the sky
only to have one recovered in
australia over 10 000 miles away
so who knows maybe that thunderstorm in
the movie blew carl's house
right into the hadley cell it needed to
land it right at paradise's falls's feet
should have just stuck with what the
script said that moment instead of
trying to spin it off into what i
thought i was gonna say
and then it didn't make a whole lot of
sense because waterfalls don't have feet
and he doesn't wind up at the feet of
the falls he winds up at the top of the
falls
it's stupid it was a stupid attempt to
add living so yes you can lift a house
with balloons and those balloons can fly
halfway across the world
does that mean that carl's planning up
is actually kinda when you squint at it
plausible
well there's one final teensy tiny
little problem you know what's
really gonna stand in carl's way beyond
depleting the world's supply of latex
and helium and having to get
tremendously lucky with weather patterns
the cost see we know from carl and
ellie's montage at the beginning of the
movie that they're not exactly
rolling in the dough they have to break
that jug of change over and over and
over again to make ends meet and even
just thinking about it's getting me to
tear up suck it up matt you have to talk
about
brutal cold science but it's not like
either of them is sitting on a trust
fund and uh
buying and filling up that many balloons
is gonna get a little expensive
helium costs roughly a hundred and
nineteen dollars per thousand cubic feet
best price i can find on balloons works
out to be a little less than five cents
per balloon not to mention the fact that
we're gonna be needing almost 300
000 miles of fishing line to hold all of
them together
when you crunch all of those numbers the
cost for the 280 million liters of
helium that you need is
one million one hundred and seventy
eight thousand one hundred seventy bucks
the balloons themselves are gonna cost
you 1.5 million bucks and the fishing
line
ends up running you two million three
hundred and eighty eight thousand
hundred and ninety one dollars for a
grand total
cost of 5 million 108
302 you can't put a price on a
meaningful romantic gesture but if it
costs you 5.1 million dollars
maybe look into buying some nearby real
estate instead and before any of my
billionaire viewers out there get the
idea that they could just do this
themselves consider the following
if it takes you 10 seconds to blow up
and tie each of those balloons you'd
need to spend
almost 10 years non-stop inflating
balloons to pull off the stunt
sorry to burst your balloon but hey
that's
just a theory a film theory
and if you enjoyed this episode make
sure you hit that subscribe button
we just crossed the amazing milestone of
nine million subscribers and we're one
million away
from getting that diamond play button
guys it would validate this channel
so much so please if you're not
subscribed consider hitting that
subscribe button it doesn't really do a
whole lot to change how you engage with
youtube in general so
help out the channel at no cost to
yourself and honestly if you enjoyed
this video we got tons more like it on
the channel
and we got a lot more coming down the
way to wind up 2020 so the year might
suck but hopefully these videos make you
feel a little bit happier give you a
little bit of a distraction help remind
you of movies that are out
and might make you feel a little bit
better about life so hit the subscribe
button we're here for you
we appreciate it when you're here for us
i'll see you all next week